hello how y'all doing ready the clouds
have been fantastic I'm super happy that
I was actually able to get here as my
first Cascadia J s been meaning to come
for a couple of years it's been
absolutely phenomenal unfortunately
after the talk I'm gonna have to walk
off the stage and right out to the lift
the airport I'm gonna miss the party
tonight I hope y'all have fun it's
something an absolute blast
so I'm James J a snow online pretty much
everywhere it's whitter github
you've gmail you know feel free to reach
out anytime if you want to talk about
node we're contributing to open source I
work for these folks are a company
headquartered on the southern coast of
Ireland a tiny little village you would
have no idea that there was an
international software company there
there's about a hundred and thirty of us
spread about over 24 countries they pay
me to work on node full-time my
literally on the platform itself and I
also manage the consulting team there so
not only do I get to build node I get to
help go out and teach people how to use
it and how to use it better so it you
know it's really exciting for me because
you know I get to see every day they do
the really amazing things that people
are using node for but they also get to
see the kind of the misconceptions or
the mistakes that are made not from the
fault you know from the engineering
teams faults but largely due to
misconceptions of the programming
language things that we did not
communicate properly about the platform
how it works and there's a lot of
misconception out there about how the
node internals actually function for the
past probably a year whenever a customer
comes to our team and they're saying
well our node app is kind of slow we
need to figure out why my first question
is are you using promises and if they
say yeah my first response is you're
using them wrong because typically folks
are actually using them wrong and it's
and it's not their fault it's just the
promise abstraction there are some
nuances about it and
how it interacts with node and the event
loop and things like next tick and
timers and you know all these you know
different things that can really trip
some folks up so I'm here to talk a
little bit about you know how all this
stuff comes together so a lot of people
see node kinda like this some people
think it's a toy right I can just look
at this for four hours I have like three
of these at home you know but you know
it's like you look at it it's like okay
what's happening inside I'm flipping a
switch something's happening but I don't
quite know what's there so we're gonna
my talk about how we can peer in what's
going on and I'm going to talk about how
note itself functions under the covers
with regards to the event loop so what's
happening inside this may be a little
bit hard to read but this code prints a
series of console statements to the
console right your challenge is to
figure out without running the code
right now have a link where you can go
out and running it try to figure out the
order in which these statements are
printed there are a couple promises in
here there is a set immediate there's a
next tick this new thing called cue
micro test because we didn't have things
confusing enough set timeouts does it
promise all it's a lot going on in this
thing so it can be rather difficult to
see what is happening these are pretty
much all the ways of scheduling a
synchronous activity within node right
so we have promise we have event emitter
many meters been in there from you know
almost the beginning async/await which
is absolutely love next tick and set
immediate which you know they actually
should have been reversed in the names
the one missing from here is like set
interval and cue micro tasks is this one
we just added a couple of weeks ago it
is similar to promises among you know
when you do a problem of promise then
right it does the same kind of task
where you can kind of manually add a and
an item there that only works right now
in node in master right so if you're
building from the master or node 11 so
if you you know if you try out this code
in no date or no ten you just have two
comments out that Q micro test line
they're right in the middle but like I
said you challenge you just you can grow
it and grab this if you want to write
that down so I look at the code see if
we can figure it out if any of you
figure out the order
you know without actually running the
codes let me know because I only know of
a couple of people within note and
within another project itself they could
figure it out on the first try huh but
in order to figure out that you know to
see what this code is doing in order to
be able to reason about it there are
four critical concepts we need to know
the first one is the event loop what it
is basically how it works
the next one is the next tick Q alright
this is the thing that the process next
ticket function interacts with the third
one is two micro tasks you alright this
is the thing that promises interact with
and the fourth is this concept there's
no such thing as asynchronous JavaScript
it does not exist all right you can
schedule the execution of eight of
JavaScript asynchronously but you cannot
run JavaScript asynchronously all right
very very important concept when it
comes to understanding what's happening
within a node process and how that is
performing so this might be a picture
you've seen before it's a very abstract
view of the event loop all right it's
this thing you know it turns around and
around and does stuff right but what
exactly is it doing this is you know
this is a better view in my opinion what
the event loop does is essentially
delivering messages right so you can
imagine you know I'm a letter carrier
right and I have a stack of letters
right but I need to deliver so I have
one right now I'm gonna give it to
somebody and I can't just go and to the
next person in Port handing letters out
what I have to do is when I give it to
somebody I
to wait until they do whatever they're
gonna do with it right they read it they
figure out you know what what response
they're gonna give they write out a
response right and then and then they
tell me that they're done okay
so then I go to the next person and I
can hand them their letter and then I
have to wait all right and then I go to
the next person and hand them theirs
that is what the event loop does it
takes a queue of messages so cute you
know we're callbacks right events that
have occurred and it goes through and
hands those off to JavaScript functions
to execute all right it can only do one
of these at a time
all right one of the really important
concepts to understand is that in node
you have a call stack so you have the
event loop running down here you have
some C++ code and then you have some
JavaScript code all right every time the
event loop gets a notification it's
gonna call through C++ up to the
JavaScript all right and then when that
JavaScript returns back all the way down
to the event loop you can move on to the
next task and run the next stack of
JavaScript code okay now this is
critically important because over here
on the side are these two little things
here one is the next tick queue and the
other is the micro task you when code is
running in JavaScript and you call
process next tick it's just going to
drop a function into that X to Q and
leave it there when you schedule a
problem when you call a promise and
interview in resolves to the dot dot Ben
or dot catch or dot finally what's gonna
happen is that function handler is gonna
be dropped into micro test queue and
it's lefted there okay it's not until
the threat of execution we you know that
stack unwinds back to that javascript
c++ layer that that next to queue and
the micro task queue is drained so all
of those functions will not be called
until control returns back to the c++
layer
you know from that from that call okay
so we can only execute one task at a
time all of these tab
you know these asynchronous tasks that
are scheduled getting an end up getting
queued in the micro task queue or the or
the next tick queue unless they're a
timer which works entirely different
timer will run on the event loop either
on the next turn or some you know set of
milliseconds or seconds Africa okay you
know as the event loop turns but still
if you're going through and doing all
the scheduling it still only runs one
thing at a time
so when javascript is running the event
loop is not the event loop past the
pause whenever you are whatever it's
executing this code which means you
can't collect i/o events no network
traffic is being okay no network
connections are being are being
processed
it's just executing that code we call
this event loop delay and it's the
single most important concept for node
performance all right this is the thing
that will kill your note note
applications from from running so this
is an example you know whenever you're
doing any kind of large synchronous
activity right you're just killing
everything you're killing performance
they're not letting no do it do what it
does which is a synchronous i/o okay so
again javascript is not synchronous but
here's a trick question
had to leave it'll you know a trick
question because the answer should be
obvious it's very the fact that I'm
asking it the answer is no not all
javascript in note runs within the event
loop and this comes is a big surprise
for a lot of people now here's another
question does it all run within the same
event loop as of no ten no it does not
we now have proper worker threads every
worker thread has its own event loop and
node instance running this is all
running within a single process I'm not
gonna get into that now but it makes
things significantly more complicated
but a hell of a lot more fun so this is
gonna be a blast working with with this
hopefully workers will come out of
experimental by no.12
and you know yeah I can't wait but there
are three main phases two nodes startup
there's the bootstrap there's main and
event loop you know folks have some
different names for these things what
happens during boot strap is nodes
loading its own JavaScript right who's
doing serverless stuff all right all
right who have had problems with cold
start times
that's because node is damn slow loading
itself it has a whole bunch of
JavaScript that it needs to load and
then it needs to load the user code on
top of that right which is which happens
during main during this time it's
loading it off it's compar Singh the the
JavaScript it's compiling it and then
executing it and there's a lot of boot
up that needs to happen within node
itself to to make sure that it's that
it's able to run the event loop has
started after main scope exits all right
and only if asynchronous tasks were
scheduled so this is an example so we
have this bootstrap by JS file excuse me
and one of the statements here is this
console log right we have the
performance API this no timing object
gives you some timestamp of when things
within node kicked off or when they when
they completed this loop start tells you
when the event loops was actually
started after that yeah after your code
it started running so in bootstrap Jas
here this first console log statement
loop start is gonna be minus one which
indicates that the loop has not actually
started you schedule some asynchronous
activities set immediate when that runs
you check loop start again and you'll
see an actual timestamp there so this
initial code this top scope right
top-level scope this is running within
that main scope right
at this point the event loop is not
running why is this important in this
code if you want to start reasoning
about what this is doing and the order
of execution you have to start thinking
about what is running within the event
loop and what is not running within the
event loop you also have to start
thinking about what is running within
the the micro task queue what is running
within the process next to what is a
timer and how all of these things and
relates from one another
it is extremely complicated to visual
even conceptually how these things
interact with one another
we've fortunately we built some tools to
figure that to start to visualize this
so the first rule of nodejs performance
know when your code is running know ya
know each individual function so the
first tool that we've that we have
within those are trace events trace
events are a file format that that came
out of v8 and chrome it's a right now
it's a JSON format that gets outputted
by the engine and by node whenever
significant events happen with the core
we have to go through and actually
implement the code to emit these we are
in the process now of expanding the type
of information that can come out of node
through trace events one of the key bits
of information we can get right now is
what a synchronous activity is happening
over the lifetime of that of that
application we can use this I will show
in just a minute to visualize the
activity happening within that
application the next important tool is
async Kooks this is the low-level API
which is what we use to actually emit
the trace events to see what is
happening so whenever a new object is
created whenever a callback is invoked
the async hooks API is called this third
one it's not actually in core it's
another tool it's a it's an external
tool they by team in uniform and near
foreign-built it's all open source
called bubble bubble bubble problem
profiling I'll show you how this works
and how it relates to all this but it's
built on top of of trace events so the
first thing I pick until we have is
built into chrome itself this is the
chrome trace viewer it's a very
unassuming simple UI may be a little bit
hard to read because of the colors that
are there but it can read this JSON file
that is emitted by the node process and
by v8 and depending on what categories
of trace events you've you've asked it
to emit you pull this in and it gives
you a timeline of when those things were
occurring so this is looking at that
timing file
and we see that there was an immediate
scheduled right that was the said
immediate that we had and that is a
persistent object to exist over time
right and then at some point that gets
executed we have two of those that are
happening here we have multiple promises
and this will show you the entire
lifecycle of these of these things we
have within nodes these things called
tick objects those are the next tick
things that are scheduled on that queue
we can also see when v8 was actually
executing code and the interesting thing
about this is we can actually if we
drill in and see zoom in on this you see
it actually gets fairly complicated we
can see the exact transition points when
v8 to go you know when v8 is done
executing the JavaScript code and when
control returns back to that c++ layer
and things like the next tick queue and
the micro task queue get executed this
is extremely helpful if you know what a
synchronous activity your application is
scheduling for you to know what the
actual performance impact of that code
is you can see those transition points
you can see when this you know this big
json.parse thing you might have in there
you know how long how much time that's
taking up and what else
it is delaying now it takes a bit of
practice to figure out what you know
what's going on in here and it's not the
best use of our interface it is evolving
over time but it's extremely useful to
see see these transition points all
right so let's go back here bootstrap
trace events something we enabled in in
core if you use this command line you
can see let's see here you can see
exactly when node itself executes its
various bootstrap phases so when it when
does it start the event loop when is it
compiling its own code those kind of
things so we're going to set up some
categories we're gonna do v8 we're gonna
go node VM and we're gonna say node
bootstrap and I mean look at that
the but I don't want to give away the
order of it alright so there we have it
we can come back in here look at our
node trace file and we can see in here
there's a bug in Windows it's not
actually telling me what it should say
under this context context apply script
it should tell me the exact file names
that I was requiring and that's nodes
own library and your code that's running
in here it'll tell you when it was
required it will tell you exactly how
long it take to load it how long it took
to compile it and how long it took to
execute it and then show you the exact
ordering of the loading of your
dependencies over time and you can you
know if you look at that with the async
activity information turned on you can
also see that activity occurring
relative to turns of the event loop so
you can see exactly when all of your
your code is being run and exactly how
long it's it took dacing traced events
this is the thing that takes the async
hooks information and exports it out to
the to that trace event log and this
gets quite a bit more complicated so if
we want to take the same one and we're
gonna say node base and cooks this is
this all of this is just built into the
node binary right now works for 10 and
11 there's some support in it for 8
there are some bugs in it so everybody
should be on 10 anyway so upgrade
alright so we're gonna run this again
we're gonna come back here load this
back up and in here we see there's you
know quite a bit more detail this is
where we're seeing all of those promise
objects the immediate stew timer is the
next kicks and and we can see the
execution of these things relative to
one another
all right the the Therese Event Viewer
is good it provides a lot of detail it's
really hard to process if you have an
extremely complicated application just
this last week I was you know at a
customer we you know in a
20 and I think was a 20 second benchmark
of their code we ran through and they
ended up just in that 20 seconds they
had created something like 15,000
promises about 10,000 next ticks and a
whole bunch else the the the trace event
file was massive and it just killed
chrome when I tried to load the you know
loaded in the viewer it's extremely
complicated and there's a lot of data
that's there so we needed a different
way of viewing it so we created a tool
called clinic this is all open source
you can get it from you know yeah NPM
from clinic use yarn whatever and what
it is designed to do is help you
diagnose performance problems within
your application bubble props is one of
the tools here and it's very simple
clinic bubble node again I don't wanna
give away the result we're gonna let it
do its thing for a few minutes what it's
doing right now is it's exporting that
vet file and then it's going to go
through and actually analyze the all of
that async activity and then it's going
to give you a display of that
asynchronous activity what this is
showing you is the aggregate latency
caused by a synchronous activity within
Europe and within your application you
can explore this you can kind of drill
down into it you can see exactly what
promise has happened the UI we're still
working on it
some application you know some of them
turn out we have a whole gallery of a
really crazy artwork from this thing but
what it's basically showing you is how
long it took to transition from one
asynchronous activity within your code
to another so where's the trace event
you can see or see it over a time line
right you can see - the transition
points what this is going to do is
aggregate those and show you exactly how
much time in each part of your
application node was spending and notice
doing work right or how much time it was
spending waiting for work to be done
okay so let me show you let me ask you
this one I promise is asynchronous
it is a trick question do promises
execute concurrently there's a lot of
confusion about this I had an argument
with a guy a couple months ago who is
just absolutely adamant that promise all
executed everything concurrently the
challenge is a does it all right when
you have an async function right and
that async function wraps purely
synchronous code right then it's then
it's just gonna execute synchronously so
when you have this promise that all food
and bar who's gonna run completely bars
gonna run completely after it all right
what about promise race same thing races
that race says whichever one finishes
first give me that right well if if the
async functions here are all purely
synchronous you're gonna have the exact
same effect foo which is a much longer
loop it's gonna block the event loop
that's gonna finish first and so in this
particular case race is not doing you
any good now if those functions actually
have a synchronous activity like this a
wait time out then yes bar will finish
first and you know in the promise race
will do what you expect it to do all
right running out of time some to skip
ahead I want to show you this example
we're a quick so this is a real-world
example from an application we profile
just about a week ago all right using
bubble cross this is the high level
asynchronous activity happening in this
application it's a mess because this was
very poorly written code and we can
drill down in here and we can see now
yep there's more activity here let's see
we can find there's some promise changed
in here like deep promise chains this
this is the code that was creating about
ten thousand promises within a twenty
second run this is the one I was looking
for this is extremely poorly written
scheduling code all this is doing is
scheduling that this was about a
thousand promises in a single
synchronous loop and then they weren't
allowed to execute and then as soon as
the the control returned all that
executed all at once you know one after
the other and then each of those were
also scheduling promises I could drill
down here many more levels I'm have time
to do that but the point is you know in
order to be able to visualize and reason
about this stuff I mean you know the
whole reason this is such a mess is the
team forgot to think about when their
code is being executed they were
wrapping synchronous code with promises
thinking that that you know by
sprinkling a little you know promise
magic everything was going to be
asynchronous or they're using it for
convenience right you know hey if we're
using promises one place we have to use
promises everywhere that is a
misconception about promises and if you
continually abuse promises that way then
your code is just gonna get slower and
slower and slower because of the
additional allocations of promise these
objects and all these async up resources
and all the scheduling overhead doesn't
mean that your synchronous code is gonna
run any faster okay so that's that's it
because I just wanted to kind of peel
and I'll peel back the curtain little
bit how the event loop runs how these
things work together and some of the
tools you can use to start visualizing
this stuff feel free
reach out set up je a snow anywhere if
you want to talk about some of this
stuff need some more pointers on kind of
how these things are going or you know
how to make your node applications
faster just reach out and let me know
Thanks
[Applause]